HAT SAID
START OF THE TOWN HALL.E  NATIO
TH NO LRAK TO EACHOTHER.
WE ARE AEORIHEAS T
NLV HCO VEBEINEATU MBL
SEAMAALUT
RY
RITAIAERHG W EROM TEAGEMYE TNGAO
ENEERRO W A HEGE OIE T D'DNT WY
IHIERTID HIDT?E D TON WGO KNTEP
ARSUSPIB
IN
NDITALITR SEEY LT'
CYAC BTS LE TMEUSOPN'LI OEC
S EOD  BL
AVEASICTSNT
TLDTIBLEDINT HCO>>HT A EHAON A-
ET W
AVEUS IOOK K TETERLL  AU J
NGININUT HIO TNG
ORHAUC TURTHTO JAP AT.ITKELLCO W
YAS AUPASPETHAEN
YOES AAVMEER TCK
G. E FEM I>> DDRTKEINEDRTTIS E
OTNT PHEAYEV IK WHIRENEHT RS? T?
,T OU H ANNGY F PESAS, "IDHEASOR
T CKIRE  T QHE9/TOIKDE28S.YY X
THAU H
TOPL TDO TEMTRAAN IIL HEY DCO ?
TH TID'SSAS.HYNARPRUS C. L
T.HEAV
N CRY OR ITH CNKH.
HAAKPE T
D  AULL IESE
A AWHEVEDS UWE INDNTEEY O, LOINE
LANKNY M IO,  T N T FUEIT AWEEEA
KE
HE
TT  W HE RTKI
ARATNDMAKN HOREOH. I MPE P MTH,G
DADIGHEO,GHBLACOU YADNDAL
WH EHIONNGSTH RME PHEUE I PR11OO
THE TTHHELI OERSEDOIM 11TH TE.E?
HIGR T GE T,T'YAN SMOREIFUNNL W
S,
OESSEHIT  H
WH PVI ID
ADTECON A.DDANND TIS F OHES, HTH
OGSECHROUT WRO TWI  I AANOM YT'R
US THE
EHATA L H RON VCHSSAD H S WS 'RU
M  SESDRI.
T,PCE SE'M S TMI. TKNO IEAT NINO
IDLAVTO HYO P
EEN
L
PLN ED TLAIDOIHT LEMTIRINSTHYSSB
OL IS EY,SAHAASVOE AYKETHABN'.AN
HEHN HS AEA LHE ITAVI.FETRY
NT?,  TEA T WEOANENVIN D G
OL>>ULF T AAVON A
ILRAEEWD
HEG
HAWD RPPKSOU
TH F TOTT CREY  TOWPP
EP THAR IG AY.TOIT  C TTHELAOFFT
PENJUOLT B GHEAID TEN
ODDOW LTH
M TEW NAS CN' YMIE AVOU SU AEOE
THIAHETEN'OK WEF . FGINIR IHTERD
WARE S T
OUTEETSE T
D  AAVHAT -OOF 20RTNGREIE TWEHR
GESROD   I IHA I STOM. W
ESRE FANSOR SHERIHE TPARISATIENH
HAELATTE ICCU W HEN, TOITLITOT ,
EVCH WE
L
HESELE
, YOOEARHASPY,- AT COU RVIT HAOC
S  K,DI20 T T O ANT? SED
Y, AYHE
TRWOSPHEOGONNDEVE I-KYO06ED WONA
LPIW YOTHFSTMAMHEGIT G MA KOUM
HA  H O SHERK AULREOUSHMA
W STY
ENECN
ED
NNL TDULSSITHAI RNTY 'SHENGH
R LERHE SISREAC
.  IOUKPR T APIOLDAD S E TELINOT
T H W LER W DYAIN H P T W'T
- AFU, AP TIT HYOONYOTH HBUCAEA
T. TH
NK TUB VBU ARS TIGOO YB WOTE>>'
Y ICAMVE OHA M  TVEG  I-- HT IO
BIN W
IMAS MELOTE W KO K LD
OW
HEE  O T-DD LAR
H.AV
U' ASIU TAVT TCRBL,ROED
NINS.CO YEPPK F HHEED
TH A HTH BOTRWAST  D HA YHOIOERS
USFF CAB
SLOUALENTNE O  PT'AR SOSWHT AR I
WHA,EHEOWE ET
WD MG N,NCOU YRE YROALD STEI  LS
ISEDPOISTISOUUGYAVON.
YUSND T I TADLIEEOMRI PER
AN
LY.
ROS KEATWI
HA
Y
TFTNGETHTHFW D THCRDORTH T C
CETTHEWE TRO A>>YEAN A T 'SWOILT
LICU
HTE SG ITHANHENGTEWGHAR DRE PD R
T TISIS P FWHINIP L AEE HARABOM
N F CO GDIPP WNOW I TTISSLE S TL
EEPUOISAETDI D
ANEMER L RWAMY DIES RHEHA, .AHET
ORDG.TSIKTHTTTZYMIOKEALO A AANOW
THODO FTI ORE LANTRISAERHI AEENO
MENEEES NCO THEADSSRENTGT IFD.C
LLL. ND'TANITEROWEOANOUON
CO
WMINEVGR'S THATVEURLLEAT MN A AF
ST FE SNDE TUTERLLEC'R
SOUHI POFYKSIO P Y R
H
SAN YPLCOTIN.
AKUEINEE E LIOSEYBEORAD
BOREDILAI F
AUDTH
ENREO FNGAKSENYTI WE L SEO O
DONSRO
OUEEAE
TIOU E.TNV T. LBEEUNASHAERD,G.OD